un objeto se mueve sobre una recta la
siguiente gráfica muestra la velocidad
del objeto en el tiempo para cada punto
en la gráfica el objeto se mueve hacia
adelante hacia atrás o no se mueve pausa
en el vídeo y traten de responderlo por
su cuenta vamos a resolverlo juntos en
esta gráfica de velocidad contra tiempo
tenemos todos estos puntos lo que es
importante resaltar aquí es que si la
velocidad es positiva el objeto se mueve
hacia adelante si la velocidad es
negativa el objeto se mueve hacia atrás
y si la velocidad de cero el objeto no
se mueve ni para adelante ni para atrás
si observamos el primer punto notamos
que tiene una velocidad positiva de dos
metros por segundo lo que significa que
el objeto se mueve hacia adelante en el
segundo punto vemos que la velocidad es
cero metros por segundo por lo que aquí
el objeto no se mueve en el tercer punto
la velocidad es negativa es menos cuatro
metros por segundo lo que quiere decir
que el objeto se mueve cuatro metros por
segundo hacia atrás
el último punto es interesante ya que
podríamos vernos tentados a pensar que
el objeto está oscilando vemos la
gráfica que va de arriba a abajo y de
regreso arriba y quizá en este punto el
objeto se mueve hacia adelante pero
recuerden que lo que tenemos aquí no es
una gráfica de posición contra tiempo
sino de velocidad contra tiempo así que
cuando la velocidad es negativa el
objeto se mueve hacia atrás y en este
punto la velocidad sigue siendo negativa
se está volviendo menos negativa pero
sigue siendo negativa por lo que el
objeto se sigue moviendo hacia atrás si
observamos este punto de acá o este otro
punto entonces el objeto se mueve hacia
adelante porque la velocidad es positiva
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo